dozens of cargo ships are waiting
outside the ports of los angeles and
long beach slowing deliveries to stores
and homes nationwide
those are two facilities that handle
about 40 percent of america's imports
they have an estimated 500 000 shipping
containers waiting to be unloaded carter
evans shows how the congestion at the
west coast ports could make it harder
for you to shop
when buyers with stimulus cash wiped out
inventory at tony yabaka's bike shop
last year he immediately ordered 100 new
bikes only a handful ever arrived where
are all the bikes right now
well i'd imagine some of them are on the
ships right out here in san pedro the
ports of la and long beach are less than
two miles from his shop it's frustrating
because you can look down into the
harbor and see all the containers that
are stacked five six high on average
they're sitting nearly six days at the
port waiting for trucks and nearly 11
and a half days waiting to get loaded on
rail l.a port director jean soroca says
import shipping from overseas is up 50
percent this summer
70 ships are currently waiting a week or
more just to get into the port what is
going on here is it just that we're
buying a lot more stuff yeah the
american consumer's buying strength is
so strong and epic that we can't absorb
all this cargo retail sales jumped
unexpectedly in august as the delta
variant caused americans to once again
change where they spend their money less
on dining and travel more on consumer
goods like furniture i just hope that it
doesn't disrupt our food supply chain
nick vias is a global supply chain
expert he anticipates more coveted
related holdups from manufacturers in
countries with limited access to a
vaccine we have to have this global
participation of labor forces
supply-side activities manufacturing
transportation all of these things to
work people have to be immunized back at
the shop tony yamaka stopped taking bike
orders because he doesn't know when or
if they'll arrive i would say you if
you're interested in getting a bike for
christmas is a good time to buy it
because come christmas rush yeah they're
probably not going to have them for cbs
mornings i'm carter evans in los angeles